anti-semitism is a virus that mutates I
begin you know with the Hellenistic age
where a lot of people think
anti-semitism began actually I say
although the Greeks and Romans didn't
all like the Jews there was nothing
personal that's exactly like the Mafia
say when they're about to shoot you
nothing personal strictly business
so anti-semitism stage one really got
personal with the birth of Christianity
and the disappointment of Christians
that Jews did not accept one of their
own as the Messiah and that really was
personal because that was a hatred of
Jews not of people in general the next
mutation took place around 1096 with the
massacre of Jewish communities in
Northern Europe during the First Crusade
and that's when Jews became not just the
people who rejected Christianity but a
demonic force they became the infidel
the Antichrist the children of Satan who
poisoned Wells desecrated the hosts and
killed Christian children to use their
blood to make months of the blood libel
that was that was demonic anti Judaism
mutation 3 we can date to 1879 with the
birth of this new word anti-semitism and
that was not religious hostility to
Judaism but racial hostility to Jews and
that was serious because in the end
Christians could work for the conversion
of Jews you can change your religion but
you can't change your race and therefore
all you could do was to god forbid work
for the extermination of the Jews so I'm
afraid the Holocaust was already
implicit in that word itself the 4th
mutation that we are living through now
is demonic anti-zionism it's focused not
on Jews as individuals but Jews as a
nation in their own sovereign and state
and it
accuses Israel of essentially all the
ills that medieval Christians is you
know we don't poison wells but we do
poison the world piece we were
responsible for every kind of distress
in the universe
70% of Pakistan is in the days following
9/11 thought that it had been dumped by
the Israelis the Israelis were blame for
the tsunami at the end of 2004
they've been blamed for more or less
everything and since it's so facto every
Jew is a jar is a Zionist then every Jew
is a legitimate cause for attack and
that is the new anti-semitism that's
been born in our time it's every bit as
dangerous as the others but my argument
is that Jews must never fight
anti-semitism alone the victim cannot
cure the crime the hate it cannot cure
the hate and so I'm glad to say Britain
has become the first country and surely
won't be the last where the fight
against anti-semitism is led by non-jews
well it's led by a parliamentary
committee on anti-semitism people of all
parties who monitor on a regular basis
all forms of anti-semitism that report
is fed back into government which
assembles a an interdepartmental
committee all the departments of
government that have any bearing on it
education health home office and all
that stuff and all of those committees
come together and interface with the
Jewish organizations that deal with the
symptoms of anti-semitism so it is
basically a government-led
activity and in 2009 the British Home
Office and Foreign Office convened for
the first time an international
conference of parliamentarians to fight
against anti-semitism almost all the
participants were not Jewish
and this conference was held and hosted
by the British government the next
government to do so has been the
Canadian government which will be doing
so this year and so we've taken this
and-and-and-and refused to live by this
makes him that we are the people who
dwell alone it is true that we have
enemies but it is also true that we have
many very good friends